5分
こんにちははじめ社長です今僕はコカコーラの放射にいいわー
緊張しております8僕ツイッターやってるんですけどもツイッターアカウントの
フォロワーさんがなんと390万人います実はなんやかや
日本ゴイでございますぼく twitter の影響力が実はありそうなんで今月と
その影響力がぶりくらいなのかの経営者
をしてみたいと思いますて今回僕のツイッターの影響力を計上するためにコカコーラ
さんの高校んとアプリをちょっと利用してみようと思います
で公ゴンというアプリ前に日影さんとちょっと説明したと思うんですけれども
コーン対応の自販機で1本ドリンクを買うとスタンプが1個もらえます
で15個たまると好きなドリンク1本とタダで
交換っていきますなんで簡単な話すドリンクを15本購入するとその時点でも1本タダ
で貰えるという
コーンというアプリがあるんですけども今回ですね期間限定で友達紹介キャンペーンと
いうキャンペーンが入っておりまして
誰かから高校のアプリを紹介してもらいます
そうすると障害された人にスターズが14個
その瞬間たまりますなんか好きなどにびっこ
あってくださいそうすると1本無料で手に入ります
めちゃくちゃお得です今さらに超返した僕にもなんと見返りがありまして
僕が紹介者友達が購入すると国にもスタンプのここ
入ります3人やた時点で僕がはもうドリンク1本手に入るという
モーリンウィンド関係を築けるわけでございますというわけで
うわぁ390万人うちから見てみやー
[音楽]
ではツイート文を考えていきましょういかに僕がフォロワーのみなさんにこんな
プレインストールしてほしいそれでついでにドリンク買って欲しいと思わせるかが大事
なポイントなのでちょっと文章をちゃんと考えましょう
今季っていう言葉です結構本気でをやってるんでビックリマーク使うとちょっとふざけ
てその何でもあるを使いますちゃんと画像をつけてつぶやきますイチョウ
お願い
したそうなツアーな瞳をしてみました
何人が高校の自販機に走りに行ってくれるのか
おっさん
に5つめます今呟きました
果たしてここから1時間後僕はしたも何個キュッとできるのかそして何ほど古豪らを
変えるのか楽しみです
んまーまーまーまーもう来ました起きましたいきなり誰かがも貼ってくれたみたいです
友達紹介1スタッフ5個ゲット
ありがとうごぜこういう風溜まっていくですねおそらく
はいというわけで10分だしましたちょっと対応覚めてみましょう
うっぷびっくりした友達紹介ボーナススタンプが170戸
きております着火ラゼック生んでいた10分で35人の方が
インストールして活字版 q まで行ってドリンクを買ってくださっておりますあ
じゃあ
a 結構2に嬉しいです
はいというゲー企画開始から30分たちました
さらにあれからサンパー何か起きているのでしょうか
うわぁこれマジでヤバイ数号
スタンプさらに線240個追加でいいですありがとうございます
やばい俺凝らまずになっちゃう奥万倉ぞ夢じゃない
はいねちょっとあと30分あるんですけどもここからちょっとあんまりアプリ見ない
ようにしてちょっと最後の結果を待とうと思います
[音楽]
はいというわけで一時間経って
私は何個のスタンプを見に入れることは売ってきたのでしょうか1時間でどれだけ歌っ
てもらえたかまったく想像がつきませんではそちらに高良さんからのコース機のデータ
が理科3組ます
ん
うん
はい
貧しいあ
[音楽]
ブーブしてくれたティにょ力してくださったみなさんもう
ニっ日本ってすごい喜んでくださる方が多かったティコ嬉しかったです
ドリンクで計算すると4003本ぶースタンプ
いただきましたあっえっ事前に1本買っても結構上がるくらいの
かつオクラじゃあ人数っていうと全211名の方が僕のツイッターを見て高校に
インストールして
1時間のうちに高校の自販機まで
小運んでドリンクを買ってくださいましてありがとうございます嬉しいですね
では実際にチケットとドリンクを交換しに行っていきましょう400サンダー
[音楽]
はいというグループ linq チケットを使ってドリンクと違いてきたんですけども
足りなくて
全部付きませんでした残りのチケットはのんびりと使わさせて頂きますはい
夕食で高校のアプリを持っていない人今ダウンロードしたらすごくお得なので
ダウンロード url は動画の概要欄になります
でそちらから多分としてみてくださいじゃあいただきます
全部飲めねぇ
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ